hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast
nandai Arnout quotations microbial
genomics and direct RNA sequencing I am
Christina jewel of labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar prevented by lab roots and
sponsored by Oxford nanopore
technologies Oxford nanopore
technologies is developing a new
generation of nanopore based electronic
systems for analysis of single molecules
including DNA RNA and proteins the men
ion is device their pump that produce
ions and grid ion systems are designed
to provide novel qualities in molecular
sensing such as real-time data streaming
improved simplicity efficiency and
scalability of workflows and direct
analysis of the molecule of interest the
devices may be used in scientific
research
personalized medicine crop science
security and defense and environmental
applications products and services are
priced for low total cost of ownership
DNA sequencing or other analysis
supported by a broad patent portfolio
the Oxford nanopore pipeline includes
multiple generations of nano 4 based
sensing technologies including those
based on both biological and solid-state
nanopores for more information please
visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor for we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on
port button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and that offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar is
over please click on the CC button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Daniel Sherman dr. Turner leads the
applications team at Oxford nanopore
technologies his responsibilities
include developing library preparation
methods to allow anion users to work
with a broad range of sample types and
working with external collaborators who
demonstrate new uses for the technology
I will now turn it over to dr. Daniel
Turner for you presentation dr. Turner
right right um so yeah Christina said my
name is Dan Turner and I'm senior
director of applications of dr. nanopore
technologies I'm gonna talk about
microbial genomics and direct RNA
sequencing but before before we do that
I'll just give a very brief introduction
of who I am and what I do so I'm a
molecular biologist at heart and I have
a few responsibilities adopted none at
all so as Christina said one of the
responsibilities of my team is to make
kits and protocols that end-users can
use so we work out the best ways of
converting a DNA or an RNA sample into a
format impassible with nanopore
sequencing but also we have a group of
subgroup within applications who's who
take the technology as it is and we try
to show what can be done with it we use
that technology to answer a wide range
of biological questions so I'm assuming
that some people watching this
presentation will know a lot about
Oxford nanopore technologies and how it
all works but as some of you might not
know anything about it so I'm going to
spend the first few minutes talking
about what the technology is and how it
works so this slide illustrates Oxford
unopposed vision for the complete
end-to-end solution from sample to
analyze results so we're not just a
company that makes a DNA or an RNA
sequencer but we make the whole
end-to-end process from sample whether
load belief cell culture and whatever
through to the sample extraction library
preparation in sequencing to the full
analysis of results so returning the
biological information that the
experiment was set out to investigate
you might have heard about sub
Promethean which is a scaleable
high-throughput standalone device but
for this presentation I'll be focusing
on the benign which is a lower
throughput device portable it uses
exactly the same sensing chemistry as
premier phone so everything that's
possible atom in iron is possible so on
a phone but all the results that we'll
be presenting today were generated so
the concept of using manopause to
sequence DNA who's been around for a
couple of decades and it's illustrated
here in a sketch from David Dimas
notebook who was one of the inventors of
theof the concert in essence you have a
mana pool sitting in a membrane of some
sort and you have an ionic buffer at
either side when an electrical potential
is applied a current flows so ions flow
from one side of the pool through to the
other and as an intact DNA strand as a
student through the nopal the current
changes and we measure that change and
this is more or less how we did it today
as I explained shortly it looks like a
really simple thing but there's a
challenge which lies in making it robust
scalable in high-throughput there's been
a lot of academic research into the
various uses of nano pauses sensors over
the last twenty years
for instance detecting small molecules
such as TNT or using the sequence
proteins it's this versatility that lies
behind dr. Glenn pols preference to be
described as making sensing devices
rather than just DNA sequences so
another core is really just a tiny hole
and as long as you can get the molecule
of interest to interact with that hole
in a characteristic way then you can
analyze it but for this presentation
I'll just be focusing on the use of
manopause to sequence DNA and RNA
alright how does it work you might have
come across the concept of solid-state
unimportant various concept context but
although optimal accord does have strong
interests here the min Island device
today uses protein minerals and protein
and applause have some advantages for us
in that if you synthesize a batch of
protein and of course the more that's
all identical so they behave in the same
way and
and we can also modify them using
conventional molecular biological
techniques to give us particular
properties so for instance we might want
to put a ring of charged amino acids at
the top at the port of a track DNA that
kind of thing they process it in a
membrane it's not a lipid membrane
because lipid is not robust enough we
use a synthetic polymer and it's got
high electrical resistance we had a high
salt buffer solution to both sides of
the membrane when we apply an electrical
potential current can only flow flow
through the pores and we measure changes
in this current at analyze past 3 so the
figure in the top-left slide shows what
we call the open port currents there's
nothing apart from just that ions from
the buffer solution flowing through the
port so you get the maximum currents
flowing so when we introduce a small
molecule the red molecule button as you
can see when it passes through the port
it's getting in the way of the current
flow so it chokes off the flow of
current to some degree when we had a
larger molecule it shoves off the
current wall now I mean this isn't
exactly how things work when we're
looking at DNA or RNA but it illustrates
the general principle so when we come to
looking at polynucleotides the bases are
joined together and in the method that
we use to sequence which would cost
strand sequencing these molecules pass
through the pool intact so when the DNA
or RNA passes through the narrowest part
of the pool and you can see in the top
right figure that's the bit red next to
it so you can see about five nucleotide
sitting in that narrow spot at the poles
it's geg atc for the top down so what
this is what it is showing is that we're
not sequencing individual meat we're not
looking at individual nucleotides at any
one time we're looking at short words so
if five bases fit into the pool into
that narrow part of the pool we're
reading five bases and it means that
we've got floor to the power of five
different combinations because there are
four different types of base so that's
just over a thousand different base
different different cone levels that we
have to be able to measure that we have
to fit into the into the current range
but because we make the DNA move through
in for one base at a time every time we
move so that as the bottom left figure
of the states the the bottom base is
passed through the pauran and mean one
is entered at the top there's only four
different things that that mean base
could be can either be 80 g of C
so it means that you know we don't have
we don't have to select through a
thousand different choices we have only
four so over the course of an entire
strand we generated a whole load of
different current levels and each of
which is related to the previous one by
four by four basis and we can convert
the signals of base calls in a few
different ways all right so there are
three essential components in nanopore
sequencing there are what we call a
motor protein banana pour itself and
there's the membrane in which then
unpause it we've got a variety of
different animals that we use in each
interacts with the sequencing template
molecules in a slightly different way
meaning that the electrical currents are
different and we can use this property
to our advantage as mentioned earlier we
need a membrane with high electrical
resistance so that the current can only
flow through the crawl and not across
the membrane lipid bilayers aren't very
robust and although we did use these at
one time we now use a synthetic polymer
which is very robust it means that we
can even add blood to a midline flow
cell and it won't rupture while carrying
on sequencing if there's a suitable
template molecules there and finally the
motor protein in the previous slide I
mentioned we'll need to move the DNA or
RNA strand through that through the pore
one base at a time so that we can work
out what the sequence is and we need a
way of doing them if we just let the DNA
or RNA go through the pool unhindered it
goes through something like a million
bases a second and that's a lot faster
than the frequency at which we measure
the current so we need to slow it down
we do this using an enzyme which we call
a motor protein and the motor protein
actually served a few different
functions so firstly it slows down the
rate at which DNA or RNA passes through
the pool it also acts as a ratchet so as
well as it's just slowing it down it
moves the strand through the poor one
base of the time and it pauses briefly
each time it does this which gives us a
brief period of time to measure the
current it's also able to unwind a
duplex ahead of it so rather than having
to make our sequencing templates
single-stranded for sequencing and can
use double-stranded templates in the
modes of protein on the lines
this makes the like having being able to
use double-stranded templates makes the
loaded preparation a lot easier as
you'll see
okay so it's hopefully clear from before
but it's worth clarifying that the motor
protein is not attached to the manifold
if it was attached to the pool then if
something happened to the motor protein
such as it becoming denatured during the
course of sequencing then we'd lose that
port would lose that that whole channel
so the motor protein isn't attached to
the poor it's a test of the template
strands via a DNA adapter which we add
on during likely preparation as the
strands captured by the pool then the
motive stuff to move along the Strand
feeding it through the portland-based at
time the speed at which sequencing
occurs is dependent on dependent on the
rate at which the motor protein
processes the DNA the motors we use a
tunable and the processing speeds
controlled by the concentration of
certain cofactors so we can adjust the
cofactor concentration to control the
speed of sequencing at will depending on
the application and sit illustrate this
when we first released the min iron to
use this we were sequencing the rate of
something like 30 nucleotides a second
in each pore we've since increased the
speed that were sequencing up to around
we first went after that when 270 bases
a second ran out around 290 faces a
second and we have a vision of making it
almost twice as fast as this and maybe
even more so without loss of quality and
what's really important to stress that
you might think they're going faster
reducing to your data quality we're not
going to do that we deal in quality
least as good in fact it's improved so
as well as attaching a motor protein
adapter we can also attach a hairpin
Advanta to the DNA and which covalently
linked together the two strands in the
jeep relax during sequencing because of
the presence of the hairpin it means
that both strands of the duplex go
through the data from this strip from
both strands is combined during analysis
into what we call a 2d read 2d reads got
higher accurate accuracy right now
compared to either strand alone which
would call a 1d
now once the templates finished
translating the motor protein is free to
diffuse away and the poor is then free
to capture the next round so it's
constantly capturing strand after strand
after strand and
the important thing for us is to load
the template into the flow cell at a
concentration where one when one strand
has gone through the port we're not
waiting for long and before the next
round is captured I mean we want to wait
a fraction of a second so we have to
load us a the optimal kind of
concentration so while we're on the
topic of 1d and 2d and accuracy it's
important to mention that in the last
year we've upgraded the nanoq world that
we used from what we called our seven to
one that we call our nine the r9 port
it's just our internal code name for it
but it's actually derived from the
Ecoline point since Gigi we've also
changed the base calling algorithm from
a hidden Markov model model to a
recurrent neural network these changes
mean that the 1d rule read accuracy is
now at around 90% which is higher than
our 2d weeds were back in May 2014
so means that the 1d data has become
more and more useful as time has passed
and its usefulness is going to continue
to increase as the 1d accuracy continues
to go up
so 1d a q 1d libraries give you improve
throughput and open up some very quick
and easy library methods which I'll talk
about in a bit but it's more than that
last time so just in case you haven't
seen many here's a look at one
so it's handheld unfortunately came
without one but it fits into the palm of
your hand which means that it's it's
possible to using the nine outside of
the laboratory environment and then
connects to a laptop via a USB
connection the USB provides the power
philomon I mean that's also another data
gets transferred away from the device
all of the sequencing reaction to take
place on the flow cell and the flow side
of the consumer so the flow cell
contains their pores and membranes and
it's where the library is loaded
underneath the flow cell we have a
custom application specific integrated
circuit or ASIC and this is what
controls the applied potential and it's
how the electrical currents are measured
the rest of the device consists of
various bits and pieces of electronics
and a fan to keep everything cool
one thing that I've not covered so far
is the real-time nature of data
generation strands pass through the mana
port intact and the current levels have
measured as this happens so what it
means is that as soon as a strand has
started to pass through a rapport then
that data becomes available for analysis
that opens up a lot of possibilities
such as being able to stop the
sequencing run as soon as you have
enough data to answer the question that
you set out to answer well put another
way you can leave the device running
until you see the thing that you want to
see it also means that you can perform
something akin to sequence capture
except that rather than being a part of
the library program we can do sequence
capture as part of like repair of course
but this is another way so instead of it
being part of like decrepit can be done
on the device so unit sequence the first
few bases of a strand and if that
strength is not from the region or from
the increment of interest you can reject
that strand by reversing the potential
on that poor individually so this is
called as a method called read until
then it's being pioneered by dr. Matt
Luce University of Macedon it's probably
some very neat stuff on this at any
given time 512 single nanopores are
capable of sequencing and each naina
pool acts independently and it's
individually electrically addressable so
what I mean is that the signals obtain
different single molecules and the
signal molecule molecule nature of it
means that we don't have any phasing
issues which can limit the read length
of some sequencing by synthesis
platforms also the electrical
measurement that we use they don't
result in nanopore amount of damage so
the quality of the signal doesn't
deteriorate over time so that means both
of those things together mean that there
are really no limitations to the read
length of the technology and it has been
shown to be capable producing very very
long sequencing reads as far as we can
tell the only thing that limits the read
length that you're going to get for them
and I'm it's the quality of the input
DNA so if having heard about that you're
interested in having a go with them and
I it is available it's been commercially
available for quite some time now
I'd encourage you to go to Nana for
techcom for more information on
so the lots of people who are using my
nines and a lot of people have published
work that we've done and it covers a
wide range of different project areas a
good place to browse this if you want to
read more about what's been published
I'm using technology on our website at
publications nanopore techcom right I'm
gonna move on to do more technical
things as I said at the start one of the
responsibilities of the applications
group is like a collaboration so how
it's an extracted DNA and RNA into a
form of compatibility manipur sensing
device I'll deal with RNA separately and
I'll start by you know by outlining how
our DNA library perhaps work so if you
only take away three things about the
technology it should be that firstly we
can secret incredibly long fragments of
DNA greater than 100 kilobases and this
can be extremely helpful for de novo
assembly or further looking at the
phasing of snips over long distances
secondly we generate data in real time
so it means that we can get a very short
time to result it also means that we can
monitor the success and completeness of
an experiment while the sequencing is
being done so we don't have to wait till
the end of the run before we can make
that that cool we can do it again and
thirdly as I've said the device is
portable so it can be used outside of a
laboratory environment so let's start
with libraries and so we can get into
that let's start the among reads bit by
talking about how sequencing libraries
it prepares in the night so library
preparation is the process of converting
extracted genomic DNA to RNA later
layered so it's the process of
converting extracted genomic DNA or
amplicons into a format that's
compatible with the sequencing system so
in the figure on the left and the pane
on the Left we've got our standard
genomic DNA library it's quick and
straightforward to perform and it's
capable of generating very long
fragments of DNA which in turn will
cleanly long reads so the user can share
their DNA at the start if they like now
sharing DNA isn't a prerequisite and
it's clearly not what you would want to
do if you want to generate very long
reads but it doesn't make sense for some
applications and I'll talk a bit more
about it in a minute
so after sharing or not so when you
shared in
physically it means that you have
unpredictable ends on your DNA fragments
and so to attach adapters to that is
difficult because you don't know what
the sequence of the overhang needs to be
so the next step we do after shaving is
to polish those ends so if you have a
three prime overhang you chew it back if
you have a recess three prime end you
fill it in so you generate tens they
don't
blunt the five prime end doesn't really
do anything during the stage it gets
phosphorylated but that's about it it
doesn't get extended or or trimmed in
any way once you have blunt
phosphorylated ends we had a single
deoxyadenosine base to the three prime
ends this all happens in one step called
end prep we can then ligates on tea
table dances if you're making a 1d
library you like eight on a forty
adapter at both ends attractive your
fragment we call this a leader adapter
and the adapter has got various features
which increase the efficiency of the
sequencing reaction so it's got a
single-stranded section which means that
the strands are more easily captured by
the porn it's the ability of the Strand
to thread into the pool if it has
secondary structure then it's not going
to go to thread very well so we have a
low secondary structure it also has the
motor protein pre-loaded onto it so it
means that all strands that find their
way to the pool have got the motor
protein on them so it means that the law
passed through the pore of that control
speed that we need the adapter region
has also got a region to which we
hybridize at tether on what we call its
Heather on the on the nucleotide this is
increases the sensitivity several
thousand fold and it works by having a
hydrophobic group on one end and that
means that the strands of DNA are able
to associate with the hydrophobic
membrane in which then of course it's
the adapter that finally it's also got a
feature that stops the motor protein
from working its way along the DNA
strand until that strand is captured by
the pool so even though you have many
template strands diffusing around
they're not the motor protein doesn't
work its way along with them until that
strand gets captured by the pore so you
get longer reads and various other
efficiency savings if you're making the
2d library then you make me use mixture
of adapters so one of the adapters is
the leader adapter that I just made
and the others are happen in that
connects the two strands energy flux
till add a strand to be sequence
followed by two reverse complements all
part of the same sequence in weed which
means that we get to mix of the DNA and
we use that to sequence with greater
accuracy now back to the fragmentation
question unless you need very long reads
in other words reads that are run within
about twenty kilobases then we'd
normally recommend that you do shave the
DNA before you start and the reason for
this is that very long fragments of DNA
are fragile so if you have fragments of
let's say 50 kilobases there's a high
risk that when you go through the
library prep those strands will snap at
some point and if you get to the end of
the library prep snapping has happened
sheering it means that your strands may
not have an adapter at both ends so not
ideal I mean it's worse for 2d libraries
than it's the 1d language but it's still
not ideal whichever type of like that
you're making so shearing the start of
the experiment if you can if you want if
you don't need super long reach means
that you can bring all of your strands
to a safe kind of size which means that
they won't be shared during the reaction
and so that's that can be quite good it
also means that your throughput can be
slightly high so the library prep looks
similar to other next generation
sequencing likely protocol it was a
couple of important differences they're
worth pointing out especially you might
see that there's no PCR so it's possible
to do a PCR as part of the library and
you know sometimes it's the right answer
so for instance if you have very little
starting DNA you might need to PCR just
have loosed the amount or if you want to
look at a small region of the genome
rather than the whole thing then PCR can
be the right answer for that but
generally if you can avoid PCR then it's
best to do that because PCR introduces
bias and not only that it reduces the
fragment length and hence the read
length it also adds time to the library
preparation process so to my knowledge
we were the only sequencing technology
that has the it's capable of sequencing
the actual strand of DNA that came from
the organism of interest so not a
synthetic copy as the second difference
is that we don't routinely perform sly
selection as part of the library so we
don't run our library in a gel and cut
out a slice just so that we have the
knife and narrow size distribution the
reason that we don't need to
this is because none opposed randomly
and constantly sample strands from
solution it's possibly a little bit
misleading we do do a bead cleaner which
has got a selection capability built
into it but we don't do and don't need
to run a fragment in the gel turns out
if you want very long reads the first
thing to say if if I haven't done so
already is that we haven't observed an
upper limit so the read length of a
mini-me so the read length that you get
is directly dependent on the fragment
length of the input material so in other
words if you put short stuff in you're
going to get short reads out if you have
long fragments going into your sample
then as long as you don't have an
overwhelming number of short fragments
you will see those long fragments so in
this light the main figure on the Left
shows the image of the complete 2d read
that measured 255 kilobases in length
and that translates as we actually
sequent for this TV we sequenced 110
kilobases so 255 kilobases of one strand
round the head in and then 255 kilobases
on the way back which i think is
probably a recommend i've not heard of
anyone I think beaten that we certainly
haven't got better than that internally
but I'd be very very interested to know
if anyone makes Tony has so you can see
if you look at the the trace at the
bottom about half way through the event
we reach the happen and it happened
contains a sequence motif that's easily
identifiable by the basic Linux software
and it indicates that it's a genuine to
DVD so once you go into happen you get
to the compliment of the strand the
reverse complements and then finally at
the end of the Strand it's a bit hard to
see on this because the lines are very
fine but the Strand exits the pool and
then the corner turns to the open door
states that I showed earlier ready for
the next time to be captured so it all
comes down to the how you how you
extracted the DNA how intact the DNA is
that you've pursued that you're making a
library out of this sample was made from
an e coli Perret where the DNA was
extracted using a cotton 500 tip which
we've had some pretty good success with
so we are working on getting longer and
longer fragments and it's going to take
improvements to our sample extraction
under the library crack technique is
because these are what limits the read
length so as I've said
the Riverland that you get out of an
anion is the product of the Fed unless
that you put in we haven't found yet an
extraction technique technique that we
can rely on to only produce long
segments and if anyone is aware of one
of these that doesn't have some short
fragments there they need to really like
to hear that so please get in touch and
let me know because even if short
fragments don't contribute much to mass
in the final sample we can have quite a
high molarity and if you don't want to
see them then you don't want to waste a
sequencing time on it
you mean time until we find an improved
extraction method we're working with
sage will make the Pippin prep to enrich
for long fragments present in the sample
so using my blue piping we've developed
a library prep protocol to enrich from
molecules that are 14 kilobases of
longer that's all very impressive you
might say but what's the benefit of that
why bother why do I need long reads well
the most obvious use is for de novo
assembly so assembly of genomes is is
comparable to putting together a puzzle
it's easier the bigger the pieces in you
have and the Plus on the right at the
bottom right it shows the correlation
between coverage of the data and the
library fragment length and how many
contexts you get out of assembly for a
specific bacteria in this case we used a
species of flavor bacterium that we
found going in the river outside the
Atlantic or office and we found that
it's a particularly difficult genome to
assemble and there's a lot of data
contained within the graph but basically
what it's showing is that the short of
the reads you try an assemble the more
you need the greater the coverage needs
to be we found that if we had something
like 20 kilobase fragments only 20 KB
and Lango
we were able to get a single contact
assembly out from 24 coverage so as you
might expect wrong reads also simplified
method genomic assembly which is where
you have a mixture of different genomes
present in the sample and this this
figure illustrates our pipeline that
we've been using with assemble genomes
from complex genomic sample using
available software such as you know
correcting a canoe so as you might know
if you've heard any of us talking before
anyone from the applications group one
sample that we do like to look at is DNA
that's been extracted from raw
unpasteurized cow's milk and just to
make it more interesting for us we let
it ferment
I suppose we'll all go rancid in a fume
come in for a couple of weeks just so
that the backs here
in there giving the opportunity to grow
so that we had a lot in DNA to look at
so if sequence is quite a lot we've
generated around a bigger basis of
sequence from it
and we know that there are quite a few
different species in though when we run
the species the sequences through the
pipeline shown in the previous slide the
assembly point when we get out about 35
counties that are over a hundred
kilobases long and with an average of
about three hundred kilobases when we
bless these contexts we find that we can
get to a contact of about five mega
bases matching something called hafnia
al VI which is in the genus of the
enteric bacteria see a family and it's
pretty much the complete genome as shown
in the moment plus on the right or the
left of it it's a commensal of the human
gastrointestinal appendage enik we also
get enclosed a complete assembly for
leuconostoc messenger a messenger id's a
bacterium is associated with lactic acid
production so hopefully that's convinced
you even if my pronunciation hasn't but
hopefully the data is convince you that
we can get long reads and for some
applications this is a very good thing
so far I've only spoken about how to
prepare and run libraries made from DNA
on human I'm it's also possible to
sequence RNA directly using nanopores so
now of course a very versatile analysis
tools as long as you can get like I said
the molecule of interest to interact
with the core in a characteristic way
then you can analyze it so as I think I
mentioned earlier when we sequence the
DNA without luciana we're unique in
being able to look at the actual
molecules that existed in the sample
that came from cells or from the
organism
Ramat looking at the products of a
synthesis reaction we can do the same
thing to RNA and nobody's ever been able
to do this before so other people might
have said that the sequencing method is
direct and they might have even called
the sequencing method direct but they're
not looking at the RNA so really we are
unique in that we are sequencing the RNA
we're analyzing the RNA by looking at
the RNA superficially if you look at the
figure on the right when we look at a
strand of RNA passing through our
standard pour the standard portal use of
DNA as well we get a squiggle of current
levels that looks pretty much the same
as if the strand with DNA but the
current levels are all different so it
means that we need to tune our base
color differently on
this is something that we're in the
process of doing right now and though
the accuracy of our RNA sequencing
method is on the low side right now we
should see substantial improvement in
accuracy as we continue to train the
best caller just like we saw with DNA
over the last few months we can prepare
the RNA for sequencing in a few
different ways in the slide here on the
left I'm showing a method in which a
cDNA strand is synthesized but it's not
analyzed it's not seized it doesn't go
through the pool it's possible to
sequence the RNA without making this
strand but for some reason the cDNA
strand being present it somehow helps
with the throughput when intending to
get rid of this step before too long
because it's a lot quicker to make the
libraries without it and it's less
confusing conceptually but we're not
sequencing that the cDNA strand just the
army so we want to take the straight of
this works so we took poly a enriched
RNA from the yeast strain s2 to HC and
we sequence with that we then matched
those reeds to the East transcriptome
yeast transcriptome using bwa men as you
might expect from a growing the East
culture these are amazing mostly
ribosomal or they're involved in
metabolism a lot of the reads correspond
to the complete transcripts as the
figure on the top left shows there's a
slight decrease in weed count going from
right to left for each transcript so
that indicates that we're not getting to
the end even though we all get at the
end of the transcripts in most cases
we're not getting to the end in every
case so right now that there's a couple
of possible explanations for this one is
that the motor protein that we're using
for RNA isn't perfectly processive and
it needs further engineering and the
other is that we're getting some
degradation of the RNA at some point
during the sequencing process initial
tests do suggest that the polonaise
degrading so we need to make sure that
we find out what's causing that and fix
it only to say them it's inside me down
to hell and they degradation it's
probably a mixture of those that were
working on both at the same time with
this yeast poly area in Richardson
sample we looked at their identities of
the transcripts that meet sequence them
mapped and we saw the two of them were
isozymes at the enzyme GA pd h or gap th
these are formed same isozymes are forms
at the same enzyme but they're encoded
by similar genes at different mos on the
genes just under 96% identical so that
given that are a single we'd accuracy
for RNA is currently below this we
wanted to see how remind
and results were so if we compare the
primary sequences the DNA sequences of
these two genes there are 42 single
nucleotide variants between the two
genes so for all the reads map into one
we plotted the number of their positions
matching the reference sequence and
that's showing blue on the right hand
figure alongside the number of variant
positions where the sequences match to
the other reference in green and they
figure here is given to the gene ytr 190
to see it shows clearly that we get two
populations so what this is telling us
is that when I read maps to one of the
reference sequences it matches that
reference a lot more than it matches the
other one so even though the reference
is a similar we're able to distinguish
between them with high confidence
because it's because the reads alone we
got a lot of chances to get it right so
next we thought it would be interesting
to see if we could sequence an entire
viral RNA genome unit in single reads so
we took the RNA from the human Rhino
virus the cold virus and we made a
library is described both on the
previous night we sequence it and you
should expect we get a series of
squiggles out many of which correspond
to the full-length genome we use last
two maps these we to a competent
reference sequence consisting of
influenza A HIV and norovirus these
individual genomes are not closely
related to each other at all so I
suppose it's no tremendous surprise that
the reads didn't map to the other two
teams but what they maps to the correct
unit it does illustrate that even with
relatively low read identity it's
currently around 80% the length of the
reads that you can mapped to a reference
you can do it with a high degree of
certainty
obviously we're now focusing our efforts
on improving this accuracy as well as a
three point it's possible to do some
biology reform with the performance as
it is here so for instance here we've
shown that we have a way of
distinguishing between man flu and
actual flu in this RNA sequencing method
we don't have any amplification either
as part of the line of prep or as part
of the sequencing reaction so no
clusters and nothing like that so it
means that direct RNA sequencing is
freed from the bias and size limitations
of amplification additionally although
with rushed transcription Muse was used
in the library prep but we did hear the
cDNA Stan wasn't sequenced so we
expected to see a reduction in
bias from that compared to see DNA
sequencing we haven't had time to do
this part of the investigation in any
great depth but we did pull 3 different
transcripts they were generated
synthetically from lambda phage
applicants I'm using something called
message machine we pulled these in 10 30
60 ratio to different combinations we
counted the reads of each they figure on
the on the Left shows that the read
counts were close to the expected values
I'm very very close indicating the low
bias something that we need to look into
in more detail but it does look like
this alone price method as you might
expect now as I mentioned earlier we're
looking directly at the RNA strands here
so the mana pool which is our sensor
touches the RNA and we measure the
current blockade caused by an RNA bases
in the narrowest part of the port so it
means that base modifications that
affect this cone can also be analyzed to
look at the effect of a common RNA
modification m6a on the current trace
the sequence - fully modified and fully
unmodified strands of the flu see
transcripts and align the current traces
the figure on the right shows a region
of this alignment and the levels
corresponding to unmodified and fully
modified strands are shown in red and
blue respectively
beneath the beneath the sequence
essentially but it's really the basic to
the central nucleotide environment that
was used for the alignment so it shows
that we can the m-68 containing short
words comas can be discriminated from
the regular RNA bases by the nanopore so
this isn't to say that we can right now
take a strand of RNA and sequence it
with no prior knowledge at all and tell
you where the m68 bases are in there
what this shows you is that we can use a
none important that we get a different
signal when we sequence modified will
receive the methylated basis compared to
the fundamental basis which means that
we will be able to train the base column
to do the de novo
recognition of m6a it's just something
that we takes a lot of work and we are
in the process of doing that right now
so there's a fair amount of work still
to be done on direct RNA sequencing to
improve the accuracy on the throughput
but it's certainly all possible and we
know having
for a lengthy discussion what to do
please check out the manuscript that we
uploaded fairly recently to the plyo
archive search for dialects online and
shipment
so that's long reads there's plenty of
libraries and RNA that I'm gonna sneak
in there let's take a look at the
real-time nature of data generation so
we released an analysis workflow called
what's in my pots our winters are short
now when is a workflow that performs
species identification real time species
maybe so as I might have said probably
many times the fragmented DNA as soon as
it's passed through the Nepal then that
current level base is available to
basically as soon as the read has been
based called which takes a couple of
seconds it can be analyzed and the one
work slow reader compared to a database
we're currently using the refseq data
base for this and the probable species
of that readers worked out the real is
then mapped onto a taxonomic tree the
results keep updating a secret in data
is generated so more species appear on
the taxonomy and read count from the
hits increases so this is constantly
updating as the moment goes on at the
moment we're limited to what's in the
refseq database but the databases we use
are customizable so they can be modified
to include other species
if the sequencing of species that are
not in the database then when puts that
we've higher at the taxonomic tree so
rather than saying subspecies is I might
tell you what the species or Genesis so
the workflow is currently it currently
works for bacteria archaea fungi and
viruses as the figure on the bottom left
shows the wind blinded prep and the
sequencing is all quantitative and this
has been backed up recently by some
recent tweets that were done comparing
not by us but by an external user who
compared the results that they got from
the wimp workflow with the result with
done on a mock community that they got
from designer research and it was very
very pleasing to see that the counts of
things and when matched the composition
of that makes me very very careful very
very closely sorry so quantitative so
what it means is that the the
sensitivity has governed my sequencing
depth so another way of saying this is
that if you're looking for a low
abundance genome in the sample
you just sequence more and it's going to
appear in proportions
relative abundance in the original
sample so to illustrate the limp works
along in a real-world application we
looked at DNA that we extracted
collaborator extracted from Siberian
permafrost
so this permafrost collaborating Chantal
our Bishop the permafrost is known to
have survived in the past thirty
thousand years without defrosting so
it's because plus is an ideal storage
medium for DNA sequencing it's like
looking at a snapshot of the organisms
that were remised in our thirty thousand
years ago so i collaborated chancellor
bachelors are saying but previously
found bits of amoeba and giant variants
viruses in a similar sample and they
were successful in resurrecting me but
infecting viruses from this permafrost
sample thirty thousand year on viruses
pithy viruses and other viruses which is
both interesting and a little bit
worrying because you know we blow global
warming who knows what kind of things
are going to be released from the
nursing permafrost the results back on
Tanana poor stuff their results are
quite interesting in themselves in both
of these both of these figures the
yellow circles mean that the that's a
low confidence wimp result what it means
is that blue is high confidence we tend
to see the no confidence yellow pills
when we're seeing so the wind workflow
here has identified down to the
subspecies level it's likely but that
subspecies is not the one in the sample
but it's a it's a subspecies of the same
species a different subspecies so for my
business in the database so that a lot
of archaea and bacteria that tell you
about what's up human environment was
like before the frost came thirty
thousand years ago there's lots of
things like nitrogen fixing bacteria
that are associated with live plants but
there's also Legionella in there which
is interesting because although that
might seem like a surprise because it's
the cause of Legionnaires disease in
humans it also infects and replicates
inside amoeba cells so we know those to
be present in the permafrost and there's
also a cycle back to arcticus which
likes the cold so you notice it's a
convincing set of findings we also found
a selection of fungi and viruses in
there as well that you might expect well
that's an example of a real-time
workflow next I'll say a little bit
about the portability of a mine
you know seen various things coming out
about the uses of Meninas in
non-standard environments such as field
hospitals in Guinea but jungle somewhere
at Mount Snowdon and so on these
examples really illustrate the
portability of the device it's hard to
imagine the same studies being possible
with any other sequencer
but there's still a limitation which is
that to get the DNA into a form that can
be analyzed on the midnight people have
to do the likely prayer and library kept
typically need bulky lab equipment like
centrifuge so to address that we've been
working on a device called volt racks
which is going to be available for early
access very soon indeed for those of you
who are not familiar with the device
it's essentially a mini insight sample
of the library preparation device again
hold it in the end it's fully automated
with all of the library preparation
steps occurring on the device and it's
powered as with the midline entirely by
USB so it makes the whole process truly
portable and easy and reproducible we
envisage just removing the need for a
complex manual sample prep procedures
and removes that you needs to the needs
of buying expensive lab equipment and it
also removes user variation and as well
as looking very cool always in the first
instance customers are going to when we
first release it the customers will have
to add extract DNA to the device but
we're beginning to configure it with
just the beginning to configure this now
to perform sample extraction as well as
not return so ultimately it's going to
be capable of extracting DNA and or RNA
from a range of samples as well as
performing the likely preparation of
choice of the users choice so all you
have to do is add a bit of sample in
liquid form press the button the first
release of all tracks is going to
support our one deal I big crack as I
showed you before and our location-based
warn and TV sample prep will also be
incorporating a bar coding workflow to
allow the processing in multiple samples
ultimately the device appeared to carry
out all the lighter perks that we have
including PCR based perhaps cDNA and
even direct RNA sequencing perhaps but
even though all tracks is not currently
available researchers have already been
able to use their minions out of its
typical laboratory environment I
mentioned a field field hospital in
guinea a jungle at Mount Snowdon
but like to finish off my talk about
other example of sequencing in the
non-standard environment you may have
heard about it if not but in way you've
been but it's undeniably the ultimate
field application which is sequencing in
space it's something that's never been
done before
we can only really be done on a midline
because of its low power consumption its
small size its low mass and the fact
that you just need a laptop to run it
additionally the absence of objects and
other moving parts means that a midline
should be less sensitive to vibration
than many other sequences we've been
collaborating the fantastic team at NASA
for quite a while now to see if it's
possible to send and Minaya up to the
International Space Station sequence DNA
when difference between the environment
in the space station and a typical Earth
environment is that there's microgravity
London is open on the ISS and something
weren't sure how well the device would
work into those conditions what we also
didn't know what the effects of the
increased gravity and the vibrations
caused by launch with the either so on
the 20th of July this year a SpaceX
dragon supply ship docked with the ISS
containing a lot of stuff but
importantly for us couple of minions
flow cells and some pre-prepared
sequencing libraries so these were
locals that hadn't prepared on earth
Lando ecoli and maps DNA so the whole
point was just to see whether the min
I'm worked and the flow cells worked
after launching during during all on
Friday the 26th of August the astronaut
Kate Rubin's he was pictured on the
bottom left started the first sequencing
run on the ISS at the same time control
experiment was the same language with
wing on earth NASA are going to be
releasing detailed data analyses of this
pretty soon but right now I can tell you
that the sequencing run was a complete
success so well next well ultimately
sequencing on the ISS can be useful lots
and lots of things so for instance
real-time monitoring on the ISS looking
at microbial growth and surfaces
monitoring the cleanliness of the
recycled air and water and ultimately
you know looking at astronauts RNA could
be a way of seeing how their bodies are
reacting to microgravity in real time
genome sequencing can be used to see if
living in microgravity for extended
periods of time affects astronauts DNA
and since we know that women are in to
work in my career microgravity we can be
pretty confident that would also work on
Mars
in case we're able to do sequencing to
see if there ever been life there
without thought I'll leave you but
thanks very much for your attention
thank you dr. Turner's thank you for
that informative presentation before we
get started on the question-and-answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button in the lower
left of the presentation window without
a lot of great questions coming in
apologize I believe we are having some
technical difficulties I'm not sure if
you can hear me or not um see okay very
good
I believe you can hear me so we um as I
said you can submit questions by typing
them in the Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and as I mentioned we have some
great questions coming in and we'll try
to answer as many questions as we can
our first question is for today will
direct RNA sequencing work on templates
with a five prime cap to the field with
these three prime I wonder if that was
just come up I'll just repeat the
question just in case I just got a
message on the screen the first question
was will direct RNA sequencing work on
some dates for the five prime cap and
the the answer to that is the RNA the
way we're sequencing RNA directly right
now it's that we're going we're passing
the RNA strand through the pool at 3
prime end first so we're attaching the
adapter to the 3 prime end of the
transcripts so the poly a tail as it
happens
transcripts what that means is that it
doesn't matter what's at the five prime
end so we can attend episode directly
though we synthesize the cDNA strand it
doesn't matter if the reverse
transcriptase gets to the end or not it
doesn't interact with the five prime end
in any way so yes we are perfectly able
to sequence with a five prime candle
with anything else with the five and
looking everything doesn't make a
difference
okay question number two yes question
number two can I do an enzymatic
fragmentation of my genomic DNA instead
of using a g-tube right great so the
question is can I do enzymatic
fragmentation of my genomic DNA instead
of using a g-tube I apologize if that
isn't the question they can see an
arrest it's just I'm not getting her
sound coming through here so I'm having
to work it out from the list of
questions in my inbox I mean I can
answer that in a couple of ways so
enzymatic fragmentation could mean using
something nonspecific such as fragment
age which is a couple of lens I just
mixed together the NIC and then cleave
DNA there's no reason why you can't use
that's it so it's a you know it's you
know doesn't perform quite as well as as
physical shearing using something like a
g-tube or petting up and down or things
like that but it still works and still
what to tell me well if the question is
can I use a restriction enzyme to digest
my DNA before putting adapters on again
yeah the answer to that is yes I would
say I've done sitting in silicone
simulations of this type and why if you
use a single restriction enzyme you do
get a huge range of fragment sizes
ranging from and tens of kilobases which
might be good but down to very very
small fragments of a couple of bases
obviously that can be cut by restriction
enzyme very well but you will get lots
of small nucleotides lot of
threatens and they're going to be
because the restriction enzyme cuts at
the same sequence each time it's
probably going to be the same things and
you'll lose these during the cleaner so
you will lose some of a very short
fragment and it'll always be the same
bits of your genome so you might have to
do a couple of different libraries with
different restriction enzymes I think as
far as a product is concerned that's not
something that we could ever release as
a product because different genomes will
be cut by different restriction enzymes
so we couldn't release engineering
restricting enzyme based tool I
understand the appeal for it is that you
know where it's going to be cut and that
can help with your bioinformatics but
it's just not something that we could
use
unknown genomes if you do know your
genome sequence and you can choose a
couple of good restriction enzymes that
give different different cuts and you
know you're not getting dropped out of
the important bits of the genome I would
recommend that you still end repair you
still blunt at the ends because we don't
have adapters that will like enter into
sticky ends and even if we didn't
probably stick together so you'd want to
blunt those just like the regular likely
prep and put on the regular advances dr.
Turner question number three are you
planning to release a direct RNA
sequencing kit for use with RNAs that
don't have a poly a tail right so the
the next question was we planning to
release a direct RNA sequencing kit for
use with RNAs that don't have a poly a
tail okay you'll appreciate we wanted to
be able to make libraries using
something that had a defined poly a tail
just for the purposes of political
development and and you know getting
them working so it makes sense to start
off with
yeah we've never forgotten that that's
not only the rnase that people might
want to look at you'd like me to look at
the the other mammalian transcript so
you might want to look at bacterial
mRNAs or whatever right now the easiest
way to do this is to add a poly a tail
automatically using something like poly
a polymerase or terminal transfers it
doesn't give you a way of enriching for
bacterial transcripts away from the
ribosomal stuff we don't have a way of
doing that at the moment so you still
have to deplete in the usual way
we recommend doing probably a addition
before you did going into the standard
okay next question please
and we do have time for one more
question how do you think library prep
might be done in space right so the
final question is how do you think
library prep might be done in space and
I suppose the question is getting it how
are you going to do
liquid manipulation when you're in free
fall so that the droplets might be
floating around all over the place so if
you've got an Eppendorf tube or whatever
with no 100 microliters of a DNA sample
that's going to be dispersed and
floating all around yeah I can imagine
that that does present a few problems
that you don't encounter on earth I
suppose one way of potentially doing it
I'm just speculating here it's not
something that we have started thinking
about not this solution to it anyway but
you could have if he just had the tubes
so that they were filled with no air in
them at all you might have a self
sealing rubber you know top and you'd
inject using syringe the liquid in there
you know something like that you'd have
to let the air out I guess to displace
that but something like that using using
shoes that don't when you in for my
stuff the droplets from going around
alone I suppose the the the
one that I would like to recommend is
using something a microfluidic device
because something like vault racks where
you don't have involved in that it's
just it's a sealed system more or less I
think if the flow so if the win on flow
cell works as well as it does on the
space station then vole tracks would
work equally well and that would be or I
think the answer to doing like a crypt
in space and when we can get sample
extraction done on all tracks as well
then the answer needs to be on certain
lessons we undoubtedly have have other
ideas right I think that's that's all
the questions I would like to once again
thank dr. Daniel Turner for his
informative presentation dr. Turner do
you have any final comment says that
I've done well I guess it just reminds
me to say thanks very much for listening
in and yeah thank you
safe again dr. Turner I would also like
to thank our sponsor Oxford anaphora
technologies for making today of
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through December 7th 2016 you'll
receive an email from labyrinth alerting
you when this webcast will be ready for
we play as we invite you to forward an
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time bye